welcome to google cloud drawing board
where we doodle our way through the
cloud
today's topic what is cloud cdn
this video is divided into chapters
watch the full video or skip ahead to
any section of your choice
whatever your app or website is chances
are that your users are distributed
across different locations and are not
necessarily close to where your servers
are
this means the requests travel across
the public internet
through long distances leading to
inconsistent and frustrating
user experience that's where cloud cdn
comes in
cloud cdn is a content delivery network
that accelerates your web
and video content delivery by using
google's global edge network
to bring content as close to the user as
possible
as a result the latency cost and load on
your backend servers
is reduced making it easier to scale to
millions of users
let's consider an app to understand how
this works when a user makes a request
to your website or app
the request is routed to the closest
google edge node
we have over 120 of these for fast and
reliable traffic flow
then to the global https load balancer
to the backend or the origin from there
with cloud cdn
enabled we'll serve the content directly
from cache
cache is nothing but a group of servers
that store
and manage cacheable content so that
future requests for that content
can be served faster the cached content
is a copy of cachable content that is
stored on your origin servers
typically including web assets like
javascript css
images and videos cloud cdn can
automatically cache this content
with just a single checkbox using the
recommended cache modes to cache
all static content if you need more
control you can direct cloud cdn
by setting http headers on your
responses and you can also force all
content to be cached
just know that this ignores the private
no store or no cache directives in cache
control response headers
when the request is received by cloud
cdn it looks for the cached content
using the cache key
which is typically the uri but you can
customize this cache key
to remove protocol hosts or query
strings
for the user's request if a cached
response is found in cloud cdn cache
the response is retrieved from cache and
sent to the user
this is called a cache hit when a cache
hit occurs
cloud cdn looks up the content by its
cache key
and responds directly to the user
shortening the round trip time
and saving the origin server from having
to process the request
the first time that a piece of content
is requested the call cdn
can't fulfill the request from the cash
because it doesn't have it there
this is called a cash miss when a cache
miss
occurs the cloud cdn might attempt to
get the content from the nearby cache
if the nearby cache has the content it
sends it to the first cache by using
cache to cache fill otherwise it just
sends the request to the origin server
the maximum lifetime of the object in
cache is defined by the ttls or
time to live values set by the cache
directives from
each http response or cache mode when
the ttl has expired
the content is evicted from cash now how
do you use cloud cdn
you can set up cloud cdn through gcloud
command line interface
cloud console or the apis since cloud
cdn leverages google cloud global
external https load balancers to provide
routing
health checking and any cost support it
can be enabled by
easily checking a box while setting up
the backends or the origins
cloud cdn makes it even easier to serve
web
and media content using google cloud
storage you just upload your content to
a bucket
set up load balancer and enable caching
and if you are
like many of our customers you probably
have services that are on-prem
or in other clouds to enable these
hybrid architectures
cloud cdn and https load balancing also
support external backends
let's get into the underlying details
now global
anycast ips provides single ip for
global reach it allows google cloud to
route users to the nearest edge cache
automatically and avoid relying on the
dns propagation delays
that can impact availability it also
supports http 2
end-to-end and quick protocol from
client to cache
quick is a multiplexed stream transport
over udp
which reduces latency making it ideal
for lossy mobile networks
that brings me to security data is
encrypted
at rest and in transit from google cloud
load balancing to back-end supporting an
end-to-end
encrypted experience you can
programmatically sign urls and cookies
to limit video segment access to
authorized users only
the signature is validated at the cdn
edge
and the request that should not get
through is blocked right there
on a broader level you can enable ssl
for
free using google managed search now to
summarize
use cloud cdn to improve performance and
reduce serving costs for regularly
accessed content by
automatically caching static content
with a click of a button
want to learn more about cloud cdn check
out cloud.google.com
cdn